one of my mentors told me something that
I thought was kind of true he's like the
men that work with you typically either
want to bother you they want to friend
you or they want to you and you've
got to figure out pretty quickly which
one of those three they fall into and
then you use that to your advantage if
there's a guy who wants to Father you
that's amazing that's a mentor figure if
they want to be friends with you then
great you know you work that angle and
the third are the ones you have to be
careful of but there's also power in
that too and I think a lot of people
today we want to like kill our sexuality
in the workforce and I don't really
think that's necessary you can use the
natural chemistry that happens between
men and women to your advantage